so the predator is back with a prequel
called prey that prays apart the prior
films and adds new context to what's
previously come before after the
critical flop the predator prey presents
a strip back in bloody outing for the
ultimate hunter that reminded me a lot
of far cry primal gonna be lots of words
that begin with a p in an r throughout
this video but come with us as we dive
into the movie and break it all down
full spoilers ahead so if you haven't
had a chance to check it out then check
out now please hit the thumbs up button
if you enjoy the video and also don't
forget to subscribe for breakdowns like
this every day without the way thank you
for clicking this now let's get into
pray
[Music]
now i feel prey completely strips back
the origins of the predator and to me at
least it reckons the versus franchise
that there was against the xenomorphs
which yeah good now we don't know this
for definite but this is seemingly the
first time that the species has ever
traveled to earth to me this is apparent
by the fact we catch the predator
clearly studying our food chain to
determine which species is at the top of
it however this might not be the case as
upon seeing the ship at the beginning of
the film naru says that it's a
thunderbird this is a creature in native
american culture that has had several
different meanings and it's an almost
godlike figure that can bring either joy
of destruction knowing what we know in
the context of this movie though it
could have become a legend due to the
aliens constantly traveling to the
planet for their regular summer vacation
i'm recording this video before the
actual release of the movie online self
director dan trackenberg has clarified
this then make sure you drop it in the
comments below you son of a [ __ ]
either way i love the moments where it
watches over animals hunting each other
and after it kills the one that comes
out on top it paints itself out as being
the best this movie is filled with
scenes of animals and humans running
with the predator constantly chasing
after them so that it can show who is
the ultimate predator they are the prey
and as the tagline says they hunt to
live it lives to hunt that's a badass
tagline too now what pride is
differently to the other films that have
preceded it is that they take things
back to 1719 so we can see things
through the eyes of naruto
naru is a comanche warrior that lives on
the great plains and throughout the
movie she comes into contact with the
yaucha as well as the frontiersmen
during this time she's taught how to use
a flintlock pistol and at the end of the
film we see that the inscription on it
reads raphael adelini 1715. this is the
same pistol that harrigan was given in
the iconic predator 2 scene at the end
of the movie after defeating the yo
chair in that movie the predator tribe
arrives and they hand him the very same
one also i keep saying
because that's the name of the species
but i'm going to start saying predator
so i don't sound like more of a
pretentious pratt than i already do find
out what language this is
near the star femur
now in the dark horse comics we actually
learned the backstory for this weapon
the 1996 book predator 1718 followed
pirate captain raphael who was betrayed
by his crew after he scolded them for
stealing precious treasure from a church
his crew turned against him but they
were taken out by the predator greyback
who had been stalking them for most of
the run a raphael went to fight greyback
but he was then shot in the back and he
gave the gun to the alien in a mark of
respect the predator threw adeline
weapon and the pair worked together now
this is probably also retconned by this
movie but interestingly it does follow
some of the original plans for the
franchise after predator 2's release
there was a lot of buzz around its
ending and originally it was intended to
set up a third film that would explore
the weapons origins like what we get
here however due to predator 2
underperforming critically plans for
this were scrapped and it would be a
long time before we got 2010's predators
instead that's why i was so hyped up
when i saw the first trail of her prey
as the origins and backstory are
something that i've wanted to see for a
long time a huge hit out to our sponsor
bloodline heroes of lithus new heroes
will be born in this traditional western
fantasy that has visually stunning 3d
realistic graphics if pray got you hyped
up to fight your own beast and take on
your own challenges then this is the
game for you the mobile game is a card
based fantasy rpg that allows you to
collect champions build kingdoms and
also create legendary heirs of your
houses in bloodline heroes of lithus the
children inherit the traits of their
parents so you can mix and match between
different bloodlines to give their
offspring all new kinds of abilities you
can combine the forces of orcs lichens
demons and dragonborn to make a
completely unique experience every time
you play there's infinite possibilities
and when i've got some down time i love
sitting back and just picking this up
and playing it's free to play on both
android and ios and we've got a qr code
on screen right now that you just need
to scan to get the game as a thank you
for supporting our channel if you use
our link below you'll get the clan of
cog for free until this there's also the
coolest characters in the game the
likeness this likeness lineage of
werewolves will give you a massive boost
in the game and they come with a
companion vulgar these demigods can
switch genders freely giving access to
more companions and there's even
potential to lead the hybrid air between
dragonborn and demigods you can create
stronger offspring by marrying the two
and right now you can obtain a half
dragonborn and half demigod air for free
what the heckins are you waiting for
scan the qr code on screen right now
click the link in the description and
get one champion token along with 100
000 gold and 100 diamonds huge thank you
again to bloodline heroes of lithus for
sponsoring this video now let's get into
the rest of it now one of the big
questions you probably have about the
ending is how did the predators end up
getting a hold of the gun for the second
film originally the comics explained it
away as being a gift that they took with
them that they then gave back to someone
who was powerful enough to take one of
them down however here we get a teaser
what's to come in the credits scene
at the end of the movie naru returns to
her camp victorious with both the gun
and the predator's head the credits play
out and in the style of cave paintings
we get the story of the movie however it
ends up going beyond these final moments
and we see several ships descending from
the sky and there are three ways that
they can really take this depending on
how successful that the movie is they
can just let us fill in the blanks here
and get the idea that similar to
predator 2 they showed up congratulated
naru and potentially took the weapon
with them alternatively they could have
arrived slaughtered the camp and then
taken it as a memento for their great
hunt now the third option would tie into
a sequel and we might see a larger
battle across the great plains between
the two sites i really hope that's what
they end up doing and whereas the
majority of the predator movies tend to
have one creature in them i think having
multiple characters fighting would
really add to the law seeing several of
them would allow for the creative team
to show them interacting give us more
details on their backstory and home as
well as how they operate as a species
first we get more naru who is one of the
most endearing characters that we've had
in the series and we could watch as she
ascends past the warchief position and
becomes something more let's be honest
invisible hunters aren't exactly the
best sportsmen and who knows how they'll
deal with seeing one of their own get
taken out sometimes they can be like hey
mate have a free gun but other times
they've shown that they'll kill anyone
mercilessly i kind of think there might
even be some in between and with so many
ships arriving as well i hope that they
come more as tourists looking for their
latest venue to hunt at potentially naru
might have just made the planet a
hunting hot spot because they finally
have a species that can stand up to them
this could explain why the predators end
up returning to earth so much and why
they also abduct humans to take them to
their own hunting planets there's lots
of possibilities and i've always viewed
the predators as being a species that
probably look around for the best spot
and move on if it's too easy this could
explain why they scour the galaxy for so
long looking for places yet they
constantly return to earth one day i
want to see chris hanson come face to
face with him and finally play some reel
to catch a predator based off the back
of this crap joke but i hope we get more
of this world as i think this is easily
the second best film in the franchise
and depending on what day you ask me i
might even say it's a bit bit better
than the first goku i shouldn't say a
quick delete delete it
now a lot of that is because of naru who
aims to become a great hunter despite
being a woman naru is dismissed because
of her gender and told to stay in her
place which could have come off as
preachy and cringy but they do a great
job with his script which is elevated
even more by amber mid thunder's acting
you really want to root for her and
seeing her out in the woods training
every day in order to develop her skills
makes you view her as an underdog that
you want to come out on top i don't even
think the predator views her as a threat
either and after the bear attack it
spots her but then leaves her alone then
tracks her and it takes out the rest of
the squad that find her but she's not
killed when it could have easily taken
her out in the field it targets the man
and not her and the frontiersmen use her
as bait because she's not deemed as
being a threat after witnessing the ship
she thinks it's a thunderbird which naru
believes is an omen denoting that she's
ready for a trial that will allow her to
be accepted however she's constantly
bested by her brother and her cries that
something else is out there are
completely ignored there's lots of
similar shots used for the pair with her
brother bringing back the head of a lion
whilst she brings back the head of a
predator they also do a neat throwback
to the original with this line
if it bleeds
we can kill it i feel like there's a lot
of references to the other films with
animals being skinned and even the lions
and gorillas are used in very similar
ways the line led the tribe to believe
that they'd taken out the big threat and
this was to murden dutch's team when
they took out the gorillas the tribes
sort of take it easy after the line is
taken out and naru's pleas constantly
fall on deaf ears when out in the
wilderness she ends up being proven
right though and after she's saved from
a bear by the predator she has to
confirm that they have even bigger
problems out in the woods naru also
discovers a large body of mud that holds
all those in place who enter it the
movie even tricked the spoiler man as i
was sure this was going to be used in a
similar way to the mud in the first film
and that it would cloak her from the
heat vision now potentially this area
could end up returning and we may get it
used as a resource during a sequel which
can provide the tribe with their own
form of camouflage
it basically allows them to fight the
aliens on their own terms and after
really overthinking about this i realize
that they can both be invisible to the
other through their own means predator
is definitely the kind of chump who
plays games on easy mode and i like the
idea that this evens the playing field a
bit manz is running around with a top
tier loadout that has an aimbot against
some dudes with sticks in a string now
naru is captured by the frontiersmen who
in many ways i feel reflect the predator
himself at one point we see countless
skin buffalo that naru ends up paying
tribute to every life was viewed as
sacred by the native americans and they
only really killed for food and to
protect themselves from predators they
spared no part of the meat but on the
opposite side of this the europeans shot
buffalo in their thousands as they moved
through the continent they did it for
sport and wasted a lot of the animal
parts the frontiersmen ended up skinning
the ones that naru found showing how
birthday and the predator wasted life
and kill for pleasure now they both use
naru and her brother to draw out the
predator who arrives in rec shop his
cloak malfunctions which happened when
dutch faced off against him and also
during the slaughterhouse scene in
predator 2. the neck gun also makes a
return from that movie too and on top of
this we get a cool shield which the
directors state it was inspired by god
of war naru almost gets decapitated by
it as well similar how dutch nearly did
in the first film there's also flying
discs that the creature uses which have
the numerical countdown on them that the
wrist device did at the end of the first
movie i also think that the helmet
that's made from a repurposed skull
looks really cool and potentially this
might have even belonged to a xenomorph
due to its shape now i really love the
bloodbath that this turned into and
watching a tree get cut in half of the
guy's head in front of it along with the
ricochet was really fun aru's brother is
killed back at camp she's given the
pistol and in a nice term for the books
she uses the frontiersman leader as bait
to draw out the beast she goes
toe-to-toe with a predator and using all
the skills she's learned throughout the
movie she manages to defeat it she lures
it to the mud pit and in a nice bit of
poetic justice she uses the helmet to
take it out it's a great way to close
out the final battle and with her
hunter's speech i really hope we see
naru return in some form or another
sadly i don't think we're ever going to
get arnie back as dutch due to how many
times that he's failed to appear in a
sequel and therefore hope that we stay
in this setting it's one of those movies
i think deserved to be released
theatrically and though i'm not
complaining i got to watch it at home i
really think that it's at that level dan
trackenberg is coming hot off the heels
of the best cloverfield movie a great
episode of black mirror and i think he
definitely deserves more stuff in this
universe i was lucky enough to see pray
early and i got the chance to watch it
two times the both of which i really
enjoyed it sucked me in from the start
and it's one of the only movies i can
remember in recent memory that i've seen
at home where i didn't check my phone
throughout it because it completely held
my attention the environment fights and
unique characters that rarely get to be
leads in movies like this all added to
it and prey blew me away if you're a fan
of the franchise or a complete newcomer
i think this film is going to be
something you enjoy and it'll probably
revitalize the series after the dead
that was the last one i can't recommend
it more and it gets a 9 out of ten
come on come on come on come on
do it
come on kill me i'm here
come on do it now kill me
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on it so make sure you comment below and
let me know we're running a competition
right now and giving away three copies
of doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness on the 15th of august and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the film we picked the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now so if that's you then message
me on twitter heavy spoilers if you want
something else to watch there's a video
on screen for you right now so head over
there your damn punk
tell you what you're better bloody do it
if not then thanks for seeing you this
one you know you know what i hope you
have a good weekend you take care
yourself peace